-President Trump held a rall
in North Carolina last night
where his supporters chanted
"Send her back,"
in reference to
Congresswoman Ilhan Omar.
And last week, Trump tweeted
that Omar and three other
minority congresswomen
should go back to their country.
It may have surprised
some people,
but telling people of colo
to go back where they came fro
is something racists
have been doing for centuries.
And here to talk about it
are the
Go Back To Your Country Girls.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, girls.
-Yes?
-What is it?
-What's up, Amber?
-I love America, but
I don't like detention centers
-Me either.
-They're inhumane.
-A living nightmare.
-And saying I don't like the
is me exercising my free speech.
But, sometimes,
when you use that free speec
to express an opinion
people don't like,
they respond with racism.
-Been there.
-Happens all the time.
-And when I went on Twitte
and tweeted,
"Close the detention centers,"
do you know
what someone replied?
-A well-thought out statemen
that respectfully reflecte
their opinion?
-Nope.
They sang the same old son
we've heard
a thousand times before.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Go back to your country
♪♪ Nobody's stopping ya ♪♪
♪♪ Go back to your country
-♪♪ Go back to Africa ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
-And that was confusing
because I'm not from Africa,
and Africa is not a country.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm from Omaha, Nebraska,
the literal opposite of Africa
[ Laughter ]
-Uh-huh.
Once, I tweeted that I thought
getting rid of all college deb
was a good idea.
-It's a great idea.
-It is, even though I neve
went to college and don't care
[ Laughter ]
And you know
how someone replied?
-With a question about how
paying for
the educations of millions
would affect our economy?
-Nope.
They replied...
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Go back to your country
♪♪ I'm afraid of things
that I don't know ♪♪
♪♪ Go back to your country
-♪♪ Go back to Mexico ♪♪
♪♪♪♪
-I replied, "Hey, that's racist!
Plus, I'm Cuban."
[ Laughter ]
And they replied, "Actually,
calling me racist is racist,
when we all know that's...
-All: Not a thing!
-Well, you know
what happened to me?
-What?
-I was minding my own business
just speaking another language
and someone yelled...
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ Go back to your country
♪♪ You're stupid, you're ugl
you're dumb ♪♪
♪♪ Go back to your country
-♪♪ Wherever it is you're from
♪♪♪♪
-But you were born here, right
-I wasn't,
but I'm a United States citizen,
so this my country.
-Cool!
-You know who else
wasn't born here?
The ancestors of everyone
giving us a hard time.
[ Laughter ]
-That's uncomfortably true
-Well, one time,
I was at a party,
talking about systemic racism,
and you know what?
Someone said,
if I don't like it,
I should leave.
So you know what I said to them?
♪♪♪♪
"Eat my [bleep]!
You think this country
is perfect?!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
People in cages,
uninsured Americans,
and crippling debt,
and we brought measles back!
[ Laughter ]
Look, I love this country,
but I think we can do better
So get the [bleep] up
out of my face with that noise
you raggedy bastard.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I hear you.
-You can't be gracious
every time.
A person gets worn down.
♪♪♪♪
-♪♪ You're not too bright
-♪♪ You deserve a fight ♪♪
-♪♪ Even if
we were not born here ♪♪
♪♪ We still have the right...
-♪♪ To bitch and moan ♪♪
-♪♪ So leave us alone ♪♪
-♪♪ If what you want is
for minorities to go back home ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Too late, bitch.
-♪♪ We're here ♪♪
-♪♪ We're not going nowhere
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The Go Back to Your Country
Girls, everyone!